without further ado the nominees for  Best Performance by an actor in a  supporting role are Anthony Quayle in an  with of the thousand days Rupert cross  in the rivers Elliott Gould in Bob and  Carol and Ted and Alice Jack Nicholson  in Easy Rider and gig young and they  shoot horses don't they may I have the  envelope the winner is gig young  thank you I'm really quite speechless  there are so many people to thank in the  making of a picture I thank the Academy  I think the producers mr. volt Winkler I  hope I do better the Masters tonight mr.  Winkler associate mr. chard off  mr. sills Jamie Greene for his wonderful  music our very talented director miss  Eason mr. Sydney [ __ ] but in my heart  I have a special thanks for a man whose  friendship goes back many years with me  a man who always believed in me when  things were not going well or going  right the man who gave me this part my  friend for many years mr. Martin Baum  Thank You Marty thank all of you